hey guys welcome back to murder without
don't one cares Jack and I'm still gonna
do my hair zone I need friends
ah oh it's lovely what's that dinosaur
that's the Stegosaurus
did you know soars through the only
metal detector when you came in ah shut
up yeah sure
at the stegosaur is it true that
Stegosaurus was originally over 10,000
feet tall and could eat 10,000 fish in
one gulp yeah what wow that's still here
it's Wars often stay goes so I bought my
very own welcome to the planetarium oh I
found you sorry yeah
areum that's like a big war stuff up
there sighs yes Wow Mars is it true that
they saw the water on Mars it looks like
it's got a lot of water if I'm more
water than land over here is that Myers
face thing moving on where's the rover
here's Uranus okay it's really bright
I hate looking at our your friend yeah
your Uranus is a is a nuclear reactor
basically it's a friend Uranus is a
friend here's the exit where I leave you
farewell make friends with Uranus oh
thank you for the tour's we're gonna as
well if you don't worry sir good boy
needs Nautilus place that's 12 that's
1250 man reception oh I won't al looks
like that's foster I need to go to the
toilet I can't get him
oh hello I was gone you're making very
murder Either these lucid mix the
murders are they together
no one's murder I don't trust you I want
your Sonic's Lindsay Lohan's crab
collection oh yes some populous repo
heartbreak what no Jack yes God Jesus
Christ I can't even see Lindsay Lohan
shaky you see up and keep it secret the
murder don't feel oh they're actually
the ones that are doing acting their
latest work my wife it's so bad mmm
okay I have an idea Oh he stabbed me
over here we have the Pokemon Sammy
pretty stab you yes
oh oh oh uh what have you haven't gone I
forgot about that
Oh oops you even murder bro you playing
on the worst shot in the history of
Gmail pillow what we need to do is we
need to each take turns giving a tour
through this planetary yes I don't think
no yeah look the real penis Suckerfish
what I should place oh yeah the penis
does he those are big penis Suckerfish
yes for big penises and that's how a
giant crab wait what's not be lost no
those are some shelves oh no it's better
for me I'm coming
yeah we're by the spider alone actually
diversity crabs and the penises are all
together yeah the big penis ii larva
things those so how do how do the
penises get in inside me well when a
mommy penis and a tiny penis love each
other very much they this is as bad as
father you know father was a cop well
you know mother was a complicated man
shut up she liked robots uh-huh okay
what about these sedimentary deposits
someone explained these little layers of
dirt where I bury the dead relapsed
whales my revisions if I was mr. dad to
a three get in the guy had done well
yeah thank you for for helping out with
that that presentation by the way that
was really nice now bury me first - oh
well that was not my tour that was
Wade's - her weight is the uneducated or
what well I I took over in this is my
area I know about whales and dirt okay
whales and dirt all right well no
nothing else that's more like hmm
you're totally wrong it's to be mmm
that's a whale yesterday all those
sticks did you turn upside down to the
south is what this shows devolved into
just random noises yeah welcome to the
bxe of the gaming center of YouTube
where we're just all right so just think
this is a blue whale it grows uh
a third layer down that's right it
hatches out of an egg in okay times of
the earth okay and then it uh basically
uh takes over Tokyo and destroys all the
buildings you know murders people swish
them and then it makes its way to the
ocean where it thrives on the carcasses
of boats
that's pretty educational as we know
boat death is the number one cause of
tooth decay all juicy Genki all tooth
decay yeah found you guys that's why
usually out of floss kids or else that
whales in a clear way who's Wade who
just walked in here I wasn't paying
attention to anything Lulu okay I'm
India all right hold on you start used
to be as a shield Lulu I'm gonna shoot
you in the leg and I see instincts it's
all that instincts no it's just like to
kill Wade
well the same thing anything the
instinct when whoever has the gun now
give the tour uh I thought I saw Isis
hmm lives Dilophosaurus if ever I saw
one I disagree I can't sprint oh right
Oh watch out [ __ ] Wade ways of
throwing us off cuz he wouldn't be the
murderer you know where I'll hi Fred
wait anyway he just came in from the
behind he came in from behind which one
lot was it the sperm so which one my god
wait I know he's wrong so balls you
Romeo who for our tell okay okay okay oh
no
oh no no no I just want to see what's up
that ladder dude is there no deaf Elijah
I'm into a small cottage Oh bullcrap I'm
not the murderer this time oh yeah me
neither
we are there mark its Market Market yes
it's me should me whoever I am he'll
never know [ __ ] oh that wasn't Park no
oh the tour I'm sorry Nick you stood the
still hasn't made you mark it's bad
lasted I'm on weds
a jack it was the craziest thing they
shot and killed each other it was crazy
I just barely made it out alive
come here you I'm in the play I'm in the
plan and go ahead and confirm that
that's exactly what happened I mean I'm
I'm in the planetarium planet area I'm
in the play areum I've got a learning
lesson for you today oh yeah there's a
lot of Education to be had here if you
just open up your mind and accept your
butt Hawks to my knife I mean you know
knowledge are you the crazy what stabber
oh and the crazed knowledge stabber I
must I really don't know anything
anymore
this exactly cuz you're dead look
footprints hmm I wonder where these
favorite is good deal holds well I've
got no I got a lovely bunch of coconuts
DDD there you are about to be stabbed
alright the blood mm-hmm I told ya
Debbie good one I what I had yeah I was
outside where everyone else died thank
you you want welcome you're welcome
I was close mmm-hmm just like I looked
up and I saw his face - so its total
days well alright del time I throw you
the water catch or not okay i'ma throw
you might well there we go well you're
ready for past and I'll throw it I'm
scared
catch me lo don't make it I don't like
it or not oh no this is
that wasn't in the world powder house
the night oh okay
I meant to throw the water what is
happening you want to play Jackie baby I
do not I don't like this game you want
to play a game of hide and learn hey you
wanna get play game of hiding still in
there